أخبروني أنني كنت في حالة قصور في القلب ولم
أصدق ذلك ، لم أستطع
فهم ما يعنيه ذلك ، لم أكن
أعرف ما إذا كان قصور القلب يعني أنني كنت على وشك الموت
أم أنك تعلم أنني لم أستطع حتى التفاف
رأسي  كانت سوزان سيجنثالر في الشهر السابع والنصف من
الحمل
تعاني من أعراض اعتقدت أنها
جاءت مع كونها حامل ، لكن
أحشائها أخبرتها بشكل مختلف أن فتاة تبلغ من العمر
38 عامًا بصحة جيدة وليس لديها
تاريخ عائلي للإصابة بأمراض القلب ،
كانت سوزان تعاني من قصور في القلب وتم وضعها
على الدواء  هذا لن يؤذي
طفلها الذي لم يولد بعد ، ستيفي ، كان
من المقرر إجراء عملية قيصرية في 26 كانون الأول (ديسمبر) ، لكنها
دخلت بشكل طبيعي في المخاض في الليلة
السابقة لها ، وكان الأمر
مخيفًا حقًا لم أكن أعرف ما
إذا كانت ستنجح في ذلك.
كان ستيفي المولود قبل الأوان يتمتع
بصحة جيدة ، لكن المهمة التالية
للأطباء في UW Health لم تكن فقط
الحفاظ على صحة ستيفي في وحدة العناية المركزة لحديثي الولادة ولكن
إنقاذ حياة سوزان من خلال الاستمرار في تناول
الدواء لقلبها الذي كان
يضخ بمعدل خمسة إلى عشرة بالمائة.
في كل مرة يذكرون فيها
السيناريو الأسوأ ، انتهى بهم الأمر إلى الحدوث ، وفي
النهاية وضعوني على
قائمة الزرع ، انتظرت سوزان 11 يومًا للحصول على
قلب جديد مما ساعد المتخصصين
في UW Health على القول بأن فشل القلب
والحمل أمر نادر الحدوث بالتأكيد
فشل القلب الذي يتطور إلى نقطة
الوجود  إن عملية زرع القلب في
فترة ما بعد الولادة مباشرة
أمر نادر للغاية ، لكن
تحدي الصعاب حصلت سوزان على فرصة ثانية في
الحياة كل ذلك بفضل شخص غريب بسعادة ما
نعرفه أن شخصًا ما كان يجب أن
يفقد أحد أفراد أسرته ، وبالتالي فإن هذا الفكر
يتخطى  عقلي كثيرًا خاصةً في
عيد الأم لأنك
تعلم أنه من المحتمل جدًا ألا
نحظى بيوم الأم بدون أن
يتمكنوا من قضاء عيد الأم الأول
كعائلة مكونة من ثلاثة أفراد سعداء وبصحة
جيدة